welcome to this video playing am bowls
at la from belgium mark the tree off
played a couple of times already let's
play the strange h6 line it's a it's not
as bad as it looks making a little place
on age 74 the bishop how interesting ok
i want to go here anyway
yeah are there some special move order
points here probably not can can play em
various move on okay I haven't played
this this night I'm thinking about
playing c5 maybe I can do that here
playing c5 in one move okay let's let's
try that I'm a bit i'm a bit behind in
development zone this could be a risky
business but I want to try to play c5
did I say in one move of course a lot in
one move this is nonsense but what about
what i thought was getting it tried to
play this and play the knight to c6
which is a real accomplishment but while
my development okay what what can you do
noach no choice anymore the problem is
the rock against the rock opposite the
Queen and the king still in the center
especially d5 kind of breakthrough this
could be it could be problematic yes now
I can always play Queen B 6 but it's not
a move that you love to make
it's not a big problem actually simply I
have this Tim portant temple and now I
have 95 and ce4 are coming and this is
in fact quite okay just as a strange
game sometimes now okay surprisingly
enough okay I'm take on knight to e7
yeah no near this is better I need to
get I always need to have a knight on d5
blocking blocking everything
ok this is bit of an offside piece on a
really on a good day Bishop e3 is
working maybe it is working really now I
get to get some points I but I need I
need came d7 and don't know is trying to
try to protect it okay come on now
whenever I get three pawns and King I
want a king d7 and get both looked into
play here he was scared probably rightly
so okay let's see just the retreat yeah
what is the Sun I'm a porn upright I've
got this porn and they have before
coming yeah let's get to get rid of this
double porn and hear me I'm even
controlling I'm even controlling the
e-file my let's say I'm controlling you
one so that it cannot ever play rookie
14 counter play
so just here right hmm
rookie to
yeah woo k 2 is in the position he
probably has to take 19 18
I don't see a I don't see ya and I think
idiot to do that okay adhere I don't
want to allow counterplay really so on
let's be be careful rook a2i then
advance the points probably yeah but i
can i can push the pawn right be4 be
three it's probably better
I could I could take my dad no let's not
waste any time on that okay if I take I
know no used to take let's just let's
just get the evo he cannot really
prevent Ruby too yeah but I have this
check here isn't this almost made
can you do to be five here
yep breaking through him with the King
King helping white resigned just going
all the way to d3 yeah yeah this was
really strange I mean the sir how
quickly this this turn to to a bad
position Queen B 6 yeah another Queen
trade I mean I was I was confident that
I shouldn't have problems here but how
quickly it got it got good worse this is
really amazing yeah this is already more
comfortable to black of course white
shouldn't be in that trouble that he got
got himself into but yeah this is a
mistake you you shouldn't put the bishop
it's not doing much on g3 and he's
controlling be eight but this is
pointless but you need to really go go
back here to to stew here to protect the
pawns and then try to just stay put
after that yeah the computer wants to
take immediately on a three i played
this prep booth and then took if he
takes I can check here and this is this
is deadly
so we got to this and here you could you
could try or think about even moves like
that it's not it's not bad probably but
I didn't want to spend time on that just
retreating is fine of course guide yet
it's upon the better structure so all
our light squares against those bad
calls and he cannot prevent before even
so it's just a technical wynia yeah
cannot cannot move yeah yeah this was
pretty straightforward this this this
strange line with h 6 s quite a good
surprise line why it has no refutation
or anything and quite often you get
positioned that are very similar to the
classical with the Bishop f5 but
sometimes with a little twist and some
little differences that allowing you to
just play a game and not having to worry
about to her fourth lines alright thanks
for watching